وداوها بالتي كانت هي يبدا نتيجه توصلت
اليها استراليا بعد عمليه قرصنه الكترونيه
كبيره تعرضت لها استراليا اعلنت قبل ايام
عن تمكن قراصنه الروس على الارجح من
اختراق الملايين الملفات في استراليا
لشركه الاتصالات المحليه اوبتوس وشركه
التامين العملاقه ميديا بانك الجمعه اعلنت
شرطه الاستراليه ان قراصنه روسا يقفون
وراء الهجوم الالكترونيه الذي طلق قرابه
10 ملايين مشترك في شركه التامين الصحي
ومن بينهم رئيس الوزراء في وقت لاحق نشر
المخترقون بعض البيانات المسروقه على
منتدى على الانترنت المظلم كما يطلق عليها
او الدارك ويب وطلبه بعشره ملايين دولار
كافيه لوقف تسريب المعلومات وزيره الامن
السيبراني الاستراليه
تعهدت بعد الهجومين الالكترونيين باختراق
المتسللين ان الذين تمكنوا من سرقه
معلومات الملايين في استراليا واشنطن بوست
ترى حتى تحليلا التقط في خلاله بخبراء
بشؤون التقنيه قالوا ان الدول بامكانها
قرصنه القراصنه الا ان الامر سيكون سلاحا
ذا حدين احد الخبراء قال انه ليس من السهل
سهداف الدوله التي ينتمي اليها القراصنه
وفي هذه الحاله الدوله هي روسيا التي بحسب
الخبير التقني تتساهل مع عمليات القرصنه
او تتغاضى عنها تماما بحسب واشنطره البوست
من الامور التي ينبغي على الدول اخذها
بعين الاعتبار استهداف القراصنه بشكل
مباشره والتاكد من عدم وقوع هدف بريء ضحيه
لان هذا قد يسبب مشاكل لدول حليفه خاصه
اذا تسلل القراصنه من ثغره لدوله حديثه
ليضربها
اضافت الصحيفه ان استراليا تواجه الخصومه
انفسهم في الفضاء الالكترونيه الذين كافحت
الولايات المتحده لمواجهتهم الا ان
استراليا تفعل ذلك مع قوه الكترونيه اصغر
بكثير وهو امر يبدو ان استراليا تدركه